There’s no shortage of theories and
questions concerning the incredibly
popular “Predator” films. From the alien's
true nature to the future of the franchise,
here are facts about the “Predator”
series that aren't really facts at all.
To begin with, one thing to know about Predators
is that they're not really predators. It sounds
confusing, but it's true. It's even pointed
out directly by the biologist Casey Bracket,
played by Olivia Munn, in "The Predator."
"It hunts people for sport."
"Technically, that's not a predator."
"Thank you."
After all, while "Predator" is a great name
for a movie about an alien who comes to Earth
just to kill people, that doesn't mean it's
technically accurate as a label for the creature.
In the natural world, a predator is a creature
that kills another organism for food. That last
bit is important. Predators, as in actual Earth
animals in nature, kill because they need to eat.
In contrast, the Predators who appear
in the sci-fi franchise of the same name
kill for sport or to prove their own prowess
as hunters, something that appears to be
highly valued in their culture. The Predators
don't eat their kills — they just skin them,
hang them upside down, and sometimes remove their
skulls and spines to wave around triumphantly.
They don't want meat; they want trophies.
By definition, they're not predators.
That said, for the sake of clarity,
we're still going to call them Predators.
If you haven't seen the "Predator"
movies — or if you just haven't paid that much
attention — it makes sense to believe that there's
one primary Predator throughout the franchise.
After all, the titles for every film except one,
2010's "Predators," are singular. There's a
Predator. And in 2018, he was "The Predator."
Of course, none of that is true. The
main Predator, when there is one,
dies in literally every movie. The title creature
of 1987's "Predator" blows himself up with a
self-destruct device after being grievously
wounded by Dutch Schaefer, played by Arnold
Schwarzenegger. The urban hunter of "Predator
2" is killed in battle with Mike Harrigan,
played by Danny Glover. All of the Predators in
"Predators" are taken down by their intended prey.
And the oversized, genetically hybridized
creature at the center of "The Predator"
is taken down by that movie's
central characters as well.
The thing about Predators, of course, is that there are always more of them.
Furthermore, it's pretty clear at this point that
hunting humans, presumably alongside
other sentient creatures from around the galaxy,
is a cherished tradition on their planet,
so they're just going to keep doing
it, no matter how many die trying.
Particularly with the first and
most beloved film in the series,
some of the franchise's most iconic imagery
comes from the Predator's point of view,
showing Schwarzenegger and other cast members
in bright colors that represent the intensity
of their body heat as the creature
hunts them through the dense jungle.
This has led some viewers to mistakenly think
that the Predator species has actually evolved
to see with thermal imaging. If you pay
attention, however, it becomes pretty clear
that this infrared imaging is technological and
contained in the lenses of the Predators' masks.
In "Predator 2," the extraterrestrial hunter
has multiple vision modes he can switch between.
And while we never see that
happen in the original film,
it's hard to deny that the otherworldly villain
here must have other forms of vision as well.
For example, how could he so easily avoid all
the traps set for him by the commandos if all
he can see is heat. Plus, in the fantastic
scene where he first takes his mask off,
we watch as his vision completely changes,
with the infrared disappearing from sight.
It's not just the Predators who die and are
replaced for every movie. Of the six "Predator"
films released to date, the two "AVP" movies,
not a single installment features a returning
human character from a previous movie. After
more than three decades of that same formula, it
starts to look like none of the movies are really
connected at all. The two most recent installments
in particular seem to bear the hallmarks of
franchise reboots. "Predators" – spoiler alert —
moves the action from Earth to an alien planet,
while "The Predator" has a new military-based
story and a title distinguished from the
first movie only by the article "the."
Of course, this isn't the case for either sci-fi
flick. Aside from the more complicated "AVP"
installments, each "Predator" movie establishes
that the previous films did indeed happen,
even if the events have been classified
so that most people don't know about them.
In "Predator 2," government agent Peter Keyes,
played by Gary Busey, discusses the events of
the first movie. In "Predators," the character of
Isabelle, played by Alice Braga, recognizes the
Predators from a description of the events of the
original "Predator." In "The Predator," the events
of the first two movies are discussed and further
confirmed as real by the presence of Sean Keyes,
the son of Peter Keyes from "Predator 2,"
who's played by Gary Busey's actual son, Jake.
Whatever character he's playing, Arnold
Schwarzenegger tends to be regarded as the
ultimate badass – and not without reason.
His godlike physique and apparent strength
have placed him on a level above other
action heroes, especially in the 1980s.
It was a time when superhero physiques weren't
as widespread in movies as they've become in the
era of cinema today. So it makes perfect sense
when Schwarzenegger's Dutch survives the deaths
of his teammates in "Predator" and has a final
showdown with the alien creature all on his own.
He's basically Earth's champion in that
moment, and he's fighting for us all.
But contrary to what you might think, he's not the
only human to defeat a Predator in single combat.
In "Predator 2," Danny Glover's Mike Harrigan
single-handedly takes down a Predator of his own,
and his win might have been even more impressive.
The other Predators certainly seemed to think so.
"You don’t know what you’re dealing with!"
After the death of Peter Keyes, who thought
he had the Predator's number and was quickly
proven wrong, Harrigan and the titular
alien are left on their own. However,
Harrigan manages to sever one of the creature's
arms, robbing it of its self-destruct mechanism.
He then follows the Predator into an underground
spaceship and defeats it with its own blade.
Other Predators appear and carry off the dead
body, and their leader then honors Harrigan's
prowess by giving him an antique gun that
it had apparently taken on a previous hunt.
Few sequels are as commonly maligned as
"Predator 2." It came in fourth at the box office
on its opening weekend, was critically panned,
and later installments in the franchise were
celebrated for ignoring it. It's not a classic
like its predecessor, and there's a good chance
you haven't even seen it. If that's the case,
go watch "Predator 2" and decide for yourself,
because it actually has a lot going for it.
It's a clear and deliberate departure from the
first movie, but that's a better choice than
trying to duplicate the original. "Predator" had
jungle action pretty well-covered, so "Predator
2" brought its titular alien hunter to the
streets of downtown Los Angeles. What's more,
it's a near-future Los Angeles, in which gangs
rule the city, cops barely stand a chance,
and everybody's guns still shoot bullets
but they're weirdly big and chunky-looking.
The aforementioned Danny Glover is the hero,
as different from Arnold Schwarzenegger as an
action star could be. In fact, it's ultimately
Glover's performance, as a detective who simply
won't quit no matter what he's up against, that
makes "Predator 2" something of an underrated gem.
In "Predator," the captured rebel, Anna, played
by Elpidia Carrillo, is the only survivor besides
Schwarzenegger's Dutch. In "Predator 2," the
hunter corners Detective Leona Cantrell and then
decides not to kill her. It also spares an unnamed
woman at the site of a massacre in a drug lord's
penthouse. In "Alien vs. Predator," the central
Predator actually befriends Lex Woods, played
by Sanaa Lathan, and works with her to defeat
the aliens. Isabelle survives "Predators," and
Casey Bracket survives "The Predator." So what's
the deal? Do Predators not kill women? The truth
is that, in theory, they might, but these movies
don't really have enough women for them to kill.
Predators — at least traditional Predators
— don't necessarily care about gender.
They just don't kill unarmed people. It also
seems that they don't kill pregnant people,
which is why Detective Cantrell is spared.
The drug lord's girlfriend also falls under
the unarmed rule. There’s also very few
female action heroes in these movies,
so it would've been a bummer for
audiences to see them slaughtered.
Anna and Isabelle are literally the only
female characters in their respective films,
and Cantrell is just about the only woman in
"Predator 2" who's not a drug lord's unclothed
girlfriend. So killing them would've just
seemed really dark. At the end of the day,
what also keeps the Predators from killing
women is the narrative choices of these movies.
As part of the gadget-filled techno-armor they
prefer to wear when hunting humans, each Predator
has a metal face mask that they generally don't
lose until the final showdown, when it's time to
give the heroes and the audience a good look at
that creepy mandibled face. Because Predators show
up to Earth wearing this mask and don't usually
take it off until shortly before they die, a lot
of people assume that the mask is what enables
them to breathe in Earth's atmosphere. If you pay
attention, however, that's clearly not the case.
The first Predator does without a mask for a
long time while fighting Dutch in the jungle,
and he seems to breathe just fine. In "Predator
2," the creature is seen breathing through another
device after losing his mask, but we don't know
exactly why. Maybe Los Angeles' famous smog is
too much for him. This same movie establishes that
Predators breathe the same air as humans, however,
because Harrigan can breathe inside their
spaceship, even when interacting with an
unmasked extraterrestrial. The same
thing is true of the alien planet in
"Predators" — the humans can breathe there
just fine, and so can the unmasked hunters.
There's no doubt the mask provides copious
tools to aid a Predator's survival — starting
with that famous thermal vision — but a
breathing apparatus is not one of them.
Released in 2018, "The Predator" was only a
middling success at the box office, and it was
widely panned by critics. These days, however, it
takes a lot more than a bad installment or two to
kill a sci-fi action franchise. Like the Predators
themselves, the franchise just keeps getting up
and coming for its prey: in this case, moviegoers.
In fact, the next movie is already in production.
It's currently being called "Skulls" but
is likely to be retitled something with
the word "Predator" in it before release. The
upcoming installment will star Amber Midthunder
of "Legion" as a Comanche woman who wants to be
a warrior and eventually encounters a Predator
in the 19th century. "10 Cloverfield Lane"
director Dan Trachtenberg is helming the movie,
so it should at least be interesting.
And if it doesn't work, that will be
disappointing, but it will unlikely be the end.
Surely, the Predators will keep returning their
favorite hunting grown: Earth's movie screens.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.